[音楽]
ana
みなさんこんにちは
今日私はまずは1cm 先の目標に挑戦し
てみるということを伝えたいと思いここへ
行ってきました
私には今夢があります
国際協力に携わることです
司会中の人が毎日少しでも笑う時間を
持てるようお手伝いをしたいと思ってい
ます
あなたにはどんな夢がありますか
また夢を叶えるために何か
取り組んでいますか
そう聞かれるとと返答に困る方もいるかも
しれません
今は高校生ですが中学生の頃の私はこの
質問を投げかけられたら全体答えられてい
ません
国際協力に携わりたい
それは大きく立派な夢のように感じます
そして
大きいが故に
中学生の私は何から始めていいのか分から
ず本当にできるのか不安でした
一歩踏み出せずやりたいけどやれない
そんな自分がいました
今日はあなたに
まずは1cm 先の目標に調整してみる
という言葉とともに
やりたいと6ながらも一歩踏み出せなかっ
た私がどうのようにして踏み出したのかを
あなたにお話しします
まず中学生の頃の話をさせてください
先ほど私の夢は国際協力をすることだと
言いました
これは中学1年生の時
ワールド七宝キストロさんとの素晴らしい
出会いがきっかけです
私が所属していたオーケストラ部の先輩で
ある野沢清沢
そのワールド疾風オーケストラの代表とし
てオーケストラ音楽に馴染みのない人や
子どもに音楽隊金を届け
世界に音楽を振るさせるために活動をされ
ています
私は音楽が大好きだったため
音楽を通して世界の子どもたちとつながり
国際協力をすることに魅了され
将来国際協力に関わりたいと思うように
なりました
こうして私は国際協力というやりたいこと
を見つけました
しかし当時なんだことがありました
自分の周りには社会課題に対して行動を
起こしている先輩もいれば実際に活躍され
ている人がたくさんいました
そんな人たちのように自分を国際協力に
関わることについて何かやってみたい
と思いつつも
国際協力は分野も規模も大きくて何をすれ
ばいいのかわからなかったのです
当時の私は周りの人達みたいに何か悪症を
起こすスキルや知識は自分にないと思い
活発に活動する人を羨ましく思うばかり
でした
そして自分のやりたいことを形にしたとき
周りからどう思われるのか
よく心配していました
そればかりでなく当時の私は自分の lc
なさを環境のせいにしてしまうしてしまっ
ていました
ついつい自分が先頭に立ちたくないばかり
に機会が与えられるのを待っていた私は
誰かが私の活動を応援してくれたらいいの
に
誰か自分の学年に人を集めて活動して
くれる人がいたらいいのにと環境のせいに
して
一歩を踏み出すことができませんでした
でもやっぱり何かしてみたい
という思いを強く抱えていた中学3年生な
きっ
学校からフィリピンへの研修ツアー
プログラムへのをし募集のお知らせがあり
ました
夫妻宮行くに興味がある私にとって振って
付けのプログラムだった感じ
方するくらいなら自分にも出来るかなと
思い応募しました
結果書類審査で落ちてしまったのですが何
をすればいいのかわからなかった私は
一つ
途上国景気をするという
1cm 先の目標が生まれました
そして旅立留学 japan という留学
支援制度に応募しました
ですがこの飛び立ての選考は新型コロナ
ウイルスの流行によって中止
規模が大きすぎて
国際牛力にどう関われるか分からなかった
私が
と城郭代金をするという目標
やっと設定することができたせっかくの
機会が
失われていくことに悶々としていました
また挑戦できないことが環境のせいにして
しまう
そう思った矢先
飛び立て留学 japan の応募
シェリーを貞作していただいた人から
コロナの c でではなくて
コロナのおかげで大
おやせるように頑張りたいねという言葉を
掛けられました
コロナが私の
機械を張ったんだってええ環境のシーンに
するのではなく
もう少しだけ
自分でまた挑戦してみようと思いました
それから少しして高校1年生の休耕期間中
オンラインイベントに参加をしてみました
もちろんこの時はまだ
初めてに挑戦することへの怖さがありまし
た
しかし一度参加してみると
国際協力の分野で実際に活躍されている方
の生のお話が聞けたり
学校外の同年代の子とジヨンできたり
楽しむことができました
そのおかげで知らないフィールドに足を
踏み込むことへの恐怖もなくなって
どんどん参加できるようになりました
そこから江南や郊外の国際交流プログラム
に参加したり企業が取り組む sggg や
esg について情報や意見交換を行う
国際会議に高校生音ブザーとして参加し
たりしました
私がしたことは決して大きな挑戦ではなく
て興味の春範囲での小さな挑戦リスト
少し先の目標を定めて今できることに少し
ずつ挑戦しただけでした
小さいけれど
調整を続けてきた私は高校2年生になる
タイミングでこう思いました
今ならずっと憧れていた人のように自分を
アクションを起こせるかもしれない
勇気を出して頑張ろうと思った私はある
npo 団体に1通のメールをしました
運営に関わりたいです
私にとっては自分発信で人の着込んでいく
という今までと違う挑戦でした
藤井大分県の高校生とともには口と口と
いう中高生と仕事との距離を近づける
イベント立ち上げることになりました
ここには自分自身が将来なりたい職業に
対して曖昧なイメージしか持っていない
こと
良い面だけではなくてしんどい面も
きちんとし知りたいと思っている私の思い
も込められています
一度限りのイベントではなく
第2弾を開催し広報や司会をさせて
いただきました
少し紹介しておくと若瑟乗務員の方や
もっとプロサッカー青春の方などに
実際にその授業について裏話を聞かせて
もらったりするなど
このケーキんわ
たくさん活躍されている様々な大人との
出会いがあり私を成長させてくれた一つに
きっかけとなっています
そして今
第3弾の打ち合わせをしています
何かしたいと
一歩踏み出せなかった中学生の時の自分は
今の様々なフィールドで活動している私を
創造することなんてできませんでした
しかし何もできなくて
周りの人に憧れていたところから
小さな挑戦を重ねて自信をつけ
一つまた一つと小さなできることが増えて
いって
今ここに立っています
を振り返ってみると私は国際協力という
動きのものに向き合う中でどうしたらいい
のか考えて考えて
さ勇気を振り絞って今できる1cm 先の
挑戦から始めたのです
それの流学園応募だったりオンライン
イベントへの参加でした
何かやりたいと自分にできることを探して
見つけたことを一つやってみて
できたから次もやってみようと
医者な挑戦を積み重ねてきました
私は思います
できないことがすぐにできるようになる
特効薬はない
わからないながらに挑戦する
大きくなくてもいいから挑戦する
こういった小さな積み重ねこそ
そして
積み重ねて得た経験こそが
できないをできるに変える
やりたいを実現するために必要なことだと
また一番最初に調整するという選択に
踏み出せたきっかけに後悔がありあった
ことに気づきました
公開があったからこそ
次はその後悔をしないようにと挑戦しよう
か模様自分を奮い立たせてくれたのです
コロナよりそのパンデミックが起きたとき
留学の選考が中止になった話をしました
当時私は中学3年生の冬で
をもするという小さな挑戦がやっと出来た
だけの状態でした
せっかく生み出した挑戦の機会が一瞬連絡
なる状況に立たされ
なぜ今まで自分は自分にできることをやっ
て来なかったのだろう
と後悔をしたのです
今は今しかないっ
チャンスを与えられるのは当たり前では
ない
ことに気づきました
チャンスを逃さずに神者らに今できること
をやってみよう
この思いが原動力となり
今の私を一歩踏み出させています
そしてもう一つ私が小さな挑戦を続けられ
ている理由は人との出会いにあります
挑戦を続けていく中で大人の方と出会う
ことがを増えました
大人の方の知識の深さシェアの広さには
毎回驚かされます
その中でも印象的だったことは
完璧に話そうとしなくてもいい
とご指摘をいただいたことです
ずっと大きいことをしないといけない
関西棋院に近づけてから提案をしないと
いけない
塗装もばかりにどうしたらいいのかわから
なくなることが多かったのですが
どれだけ小さくても曖昧でも
挑戦したいことを言葉にして相談してみ
たらいいんだと考え方が変わりました
これが小さな
1cm 先の目標に調整する出発点になっ
ています
環境のせいにしてしまっていたこともあり
ますが
自分が積み重ねてきた小さな調整を通して
司会の見方が変わって
自分自身で挑戦できる環境をつくることが
できました
今でももちろん他人の目が気になったり
勇気が出せなくて
市長の着込めなかったりすることは
たくさんあります
活動する上で自分の未熟な部分が
突き刺さってきますし
大人の方からダメ出しをされたことがあり
もあって
かつてのように挑戦することが怖いと
感じることがあります
それでも
センチメートル先の目標に調整し続ける
ことの大切さを
入った今だからこそ
やっちゃおうと飛び込むことができるよう
になりました
それが今の私です
踏み出す前は
6すごく遠く感じていた
一歩の距離は今振り返ってみるとたった
10センチくらいしかありませんでした
私でも
小さくても自分にできること
に挑戦し続け
ほんの少しずつ少しずつ進んでいっている
うちに
1のまにか10センチ住んでいました
きっと
あなたががむしゃらに1cm 先の目標に
調整続ければ
いつのまにか今できないと感じていること
はごく自然にできるようになっています
だから絶対あなたにもできます
イベントのテーマでありチョイス
あなたの人生はあなたの日々の今日の選択
で作られています
だから貴方の選択で変えることができます
新たが遠くに感じている距離はたったの
10センチです
あなたが動き後すぐに加えることができる
のです
ありがとうございました
[拍手]